this video is for students who are
thinking of applying to Oxford or
Cambridge their teachers parents and
guardians now if you're any one of those
then you probably have a huge number of
questions right now about the
application procedures and about the
universities in general and I really
hope this video is going to go at least
some way to answering your questions now
while this video is going to provide you
with some simple answers to your
questions its real purpose is to direct
you to the other fantastic information
sources which are available online with
so many available it's difficult to know
where to start and so I really hope that
this video will point you in the right
direction as a rule of thumb both Oxford
and Cambridge have fantastically
informative websites they are Oh X dot a
C dot uk' and cam dot a C dot u K
respectively and all the links which are
appearing up here will also be down
there in the description firstly some
basic questions and first of all why
should I want to apply to Oxford or
Cambridge well the simple answer to this
is that both Oxford and Cambridge are
world leading institutions which offer
highly competitive degree programs if
you were to graduate from either one of
them then you'll be highly sought after
in the global job market and would be
very well equipped to deal with pretty
much any situation that your field could
throw you there are of course many other
reasons why you want to apply the
collegiate system allows for smaller
tight-knit communities than non
collegiate universities the tutorial or
supervision system allows for an
unparalleled level of student academic
contact and both universities have
fantastic alumni networks which allow
you to connect and give you
opportunities that are just not
available elsewhere as well as the
fantastic extracurricular scene at both
universities choosing between the two
universities as you must do for your
first undergraduate degree is
fundamentally a personal choice informed
by differences in the courses
differences in the towns that they
inhabit and numerable small factors the
best advice I can give you is to
carefully consider what you want to get
out of your degree and if that does not
the question for you then to visit both
of the towns Oxford is more of a city
whereas Cambridge is more of a market
town feel and they suit different people
all else being equal just choose where
you would prefer to call home for three
or four years all this being said Oxford
and Cambridge are not for everyone
I'd ask you to carefully consider all
the information that's available online
and make a decision about whether it is
the right place for you there are many
other Russell Group universities offer
similarly rigorous and competitive
degree programs in a less intense way
with longer terms and if you feel
like that might be more suited to you
than do not feel pressured into applying
to universities where you do not think
you will be happy
secondly what the Oxford and Cambridge
look for in their students now this
question has a very simple answer the
admittance tutors are looking for the
brightest the most capable students in
their fields there are a huge number of
myths and misconceptions that people
believe about Oxford and Cambridge and
the fact of the matter is that both
universities simply want the best of
brightest students this can be
demonstrated by the student in two ways
firstly academic excellence cheaters
will be looking for students with the
best grades possible and they will
almost exclusively be concerned with
grades in subjects directly related to
the degree you're applying for though
this is covered in more detail later
secondly cheaters will look for students
who are passionate about their subject
this can be demonstrated in many ways
through clubs through reading through
taking your understanding of the subject
beyond what's required of you at school
the ideal student will be someone who
has excelled in their field or in fields
closely related to it in the case of
subjects that aren't studied at school
and has taken their understanding of
their subject beyond what is asked of
them off their own back in both academic
and extracurricular excellence
independent thoughts and ingenuity are
very highly prized by the cheaters so
try and encourage this and cultivate it
wherever you can for more information on
what the university is officially look
for they have official web pages on this
subject here and here for Oxford and
Cambridge thirdly we'll my background or
school change how likely it is that I
will get in as your answer this question
is know one of the most persistent myths
that people believe are Oxbridge is that
only rich public school educated kids
can get in and this is categorically not
true
I for example went to Oxford in 2009
study physics and I went to a state
comprehensive school when I was the
first member of my family to go to
university my background simply wasn't
an issue the tutors didn't care about it
all they cared about was my ability to
do my subject I actually made an entire
video on the subject of whether Oxbridge
admissions are fair and you can check
that out here there is however a caveat
to this question
Oxford uses a flagging system whereby
students who are from underperforming
schools who are in care or from deprived
postcodes are much more likely to be
invited to interview for more
information about
scheme check out the link here and for
information about a very similar
cambridge scheme check the link here
lastly for a discussion about what
Oxford has been doing to improve access
to students from a typical backgrounds
check out this interview I did with one
of my colleges access reps here fourth
question how do I choose a course in
many cases the subject that you'll be
applying for chooses itself I for
example applied for physics because it
was the subject that I was most
passionate about but in some cases there
are subject which are very similar that
you might be undecided about for example
physics engineering and maths or there
might be subjects which aren't offered
in schools like archaeology and
anthropology in these cases it is highly
advisable to do your research lists of
courses available at Oxford and
Cambridge can be found here and here
respectively and each department at the
university has its own website which can
be either found from the main University
page or from a quick Google search I'd
recommend that you check out every
departments website that you are
interested in possibly applying to and
in addition to these websites that are
also prospectus is available which are
either electronically available online
or can be requested in print form when
checking for this information I highly
recommend that you look at the course
structure the material covered and the
method of assessment before making a
firm decision ultimately choosing a
course is a highly personal decision but
you can make this decision as informed
as possible and try to make sure that
you can see yourself successfully and
happily studying your subject for three
four or even more years fifth question
what is the college system and how do I
choose a college now the college system
is one of the most confusing aspects of
Oxbridge to applicants and for good
reason it's pretty much unique in global
education each University is broken down
into multiple colleges and these exist
separately from the department system
each College provides accommodation
pastoral support and other resources to
its students and typically houses a few
hundred postgraduate and undergraduate
students some teaching is done by the
college for example your tutorials or
provisions in first-year will most
likely be at your college while the
majority the teaching for example of
your lectures and any lab work will be
coordinated by the department the
question of which course to choose is an
immensely difficult one and there is no
one right answer but in a way there's
also no wrong answer because every
student ends up thinking that their
college is the best in the university so
godless of what you choose you'll end up
being happy and proud firstly they'll
find out which colleges offer your
subject as not all subjects are offered
at all colleges for Oxford you can find
this out here of Cambridge you can find
this out
here then ask yourself what kind of
college you would like to live in
ultimately your college is going to be
your home for three or four years and
personally I think that the most
important criterion in choosing is where
you feel comfortable and home so with
that in mind I personally think the best
way to choose a college is to physically
go to Oxford or Cambridge and visit the
colleges you are interested in applying
to while there you can pick up
documentation like prospectuses you can
get a tour of the grounds and a chance
to just drink in the atmosphere often
the choice makes itself before going
though you might want to whittle down
all the available options into a
shortlist in which case consider the
following questions does the size of the
college matter to you would you prefer
to live in a big one or a small one does
the age or the grandeur of the college
matter
would you like guaranteed accommodation
for your entire degree would you like to
live out for some of it and do college
sports matter to you or music or the
Arts each College has its own website
and social media accounts and so you can
use these to get a good sense of what
life is like at these colleges though
this aspect is caring more fully at the
end of the video lastly if all of this
sounds like too much work
then you can always submit in an open
application and the university will
choose a college for you though I'd at
least recommend investigating your
options actually to return to a point I
made earlier about every student
thinking their colleges are the best in
university the best College in Oxford is
in fact some pieces College Oxford more
information about which can be found at
SBC oxa CDOT UK did I just show some
buyers